bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur la
chaîne de vulgarisation des instances
politiques
la chaîne qui vous explique en cinq
minutes les détails des instances
politiques en france
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du maire
alors qu'est ce que c'est un maire qu'on
habite dans un village une ville un beau
ou même une maison complètement isolé
qui est rattaché à un chef lieu on
appelle ces moments d'habitation des
communes pour les diriger et les
organiser il y un maire c'est un peu
comme le chef d'orchestre le chef
d'equipe c'est celui qui va faire en
sorte que tout se passe bien c'est un
peu dans le chef du village
voyons un peu quels sont ses fonctions
la première est de représenter l'état au
sein de la commune c'est le représentant
de l'état le plus proche des citoyens
à ce titre et sera officier de la police
judiciaire
c'est une personne qui sera habilité à
faire le constat des crimes et des
délits à recevoir des plaintes venant
des habitants à établir des enquêtes
préliminaires sur certaines de ces
plaintes et a enquêté sur l'activité de
la police judiciaire par exemple il sera
également officier d'état civil qui lui
donnera le droit de célébrer des
mariages rédigé les actes de décès ou
encore recevoir les actes de naissance
également il va administrer la commune
c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que tout se
passe bien et que la commune soit la
plus agréable possible à vivre enfin
c'est le président du conseil municipal
en effet le maire va être accompagné des
conseillers municipaux et de ses
adjoints ensemble ils vont former le
conseil municipal qui nous représente ni
habitants de la commune et nous quand on
va voter tous les six ans pour les
élections municipales ce sont les
conseillers municipaux condé ce sont ces
mêmes conseillers municipaux qui vont
élire le maire ainsi que ses adjoints
les adjoints du maire ce sont ceux qui
aident le maire dans ses tâches
quotidiennes
un peu comme un super dans une équipe il
se rend là dans le maire ne pourra pas
être présent et les effectuent les
tâches qui leur sont dvd par le maire
les conseillers municipaux forme le
conseil municipal qui prend les
décisions pour la commune et fixe le
nombre d'adjoints
celui ci ne peut pas dépasser 30% de
l'effectif du conseil municipal il est
bon à savoir que depuis 2013
il est obligation de parité hommes
femmes au sein des conseils municipaux
des communes de
mille habitants le nombre d'adjoints
peut varier entre sept conseillers pour
les communes de moins de 100 habitants à
69 pour celles de plus de 300000
habitants sauf à lyon où il y en a 60 13
à marseille où il y en a 100 1 et à
paris où il y en a cent soixante-trois
avant de prendre les décisions pour la
commune le maire va organiser et présidé
le conseil municipal qui doit se réunir
au minimum une fois par trimestre
mais qui en pratique se réunit le plus
souvent une fois par mois le conseil
municipal c'est lui qui va voter des
décisions pour gérer la commune par
exemple ils peuvent ouvrir un musée
refaire les trottoirs dans la rue
rénover une bibliothèque et des légendes
difficultés à trouver du travail
ouvrir une maison médicale où d'autres
projets en fonction des besoins de sa
commune et de ses habitants
il est également responsable du maintien
de l'ordre et du respect de la loi au
sein de la commune à ce titre il sera
aidé par la police municipale lorsqu'il
ya des élections
c'est lui qui est chargé de les
organiser pour la commune il sera aussi
chargé de gérer l'environnement de la
commune on est en charge la distribution
d'eau potable
l'évacuation des eaux usées la collecte
et le tri des déchets par exemple
enfin le conseil municipal vote le
budget de la commune qui a été écrit par
le maire et ses attentes
il décide des impôts locaux il peut
également créer ou supprimer les emplois
municipaux
on peut maintenant se demander comment
est élu le maire déjà il va être élu
parmi les conseillers municipaux qui se
réunissent en un premier conseil
municipal entre le vendredi et le
dimanche qui suit l'élection
l'élection se fait à bulletin secret
c'est à dire que personne ne sait qui a
voté porter les deux premiers tours sont
à la majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés
c'est à dire qu'un des conseillers
devient maire s'il obtient plus de 50%
des voix de l'ensemble des conseillers
s'il n'y a pas de majorité absolue il
est un troisième tour qui se fait à la
majorité relative
c'est à dire que le conseiller qui a le
plus de voix étaient en cas d'égalité
c'est le conseiller le plus âgé qui
était pour pouvoir devenir conseiller au
maire il faut avoir 18 ans résolu jouir
de ses droits civiques
être inscrit sur la liste électorale de
la commune être inscrit au pôle des
impôts de la comique pour la fonction de
maire et adjoints la nationalité
française est nécessaire mais tous les
ressortissants européens peuvent devenir
conseiller
on finir savez vous qu'il ya des mères
qui réalisent des villes non habitée en
effet six communes françaises ne lisent
pas de conseiller le maire étant
désignés par le préfet il s'agit des
villages dévastés durant la bataille de
verdun en 1916 et jamais reconstruit en
raison de la présence trop importante de
munitions non explosées et de la
pollution des sols
ce sont les villages de bezan vauban -
verdunois fumière le mot rom fleury
devant douaumont près c'est un milieu et
nous venons côte de poivre donc voilà
cette vidéo est terminée j'espère
qu'elle vous aura plu et que vous en
saurez un peu plus sur le maire nous
détaillerons dans une prochaine vidéo le
mode d'élection pour les conseillers
municipaux qui mérite une vidéo à part
entière mais en attendant si vous voulez
savoir comment ça marche je vous invite
à cliquer sur les liens dans la
description qui vous expliqueront tous
les détails de cette élection
en tout cas n'hésitez pas à laisser vos
commentaires merci à tous et à très
bientôt